what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I have the pleasure of
doing an interview with the folks behind
one of my most anticipated films of the
festival the team behind Eileen
congratulations I already said this to
you before but even though I didn't see
your movie it's special to make a movie
and to get to Premiere it at a festival
so wholeheartedly congratulations to all
of you thank you thank you so I know a
little about Eileen the book readers
know about Eileen but some of our
viewership might not know anything about
the story I'm sure you're doing this a
lot of Tessa can you please give us a
brief synopsis of what Eileen is about
oh God you know I was asking Luke what's
this movie about
um so Eileen takes place in a small town
in coastal New England in 1964. and it's
the story of a young woman named Eileen
who finds herself
um
or rather puts herself in um
a position of
um sorry this is why it's getting harder
she
um somebody please do this
it's really about infatuation it's about
finding another it's about a character
who's so alone now look at me I'm
explaining her book I'm going to be
hated
um Tessa has so massively written a book
about a character I feel like we should
try the test of like one sentence each
until we give a full synopsis I'm just
kidding you don't have to do that well
can I say having seen the film I do
think it's a film about triggers
it's a good tease I like that
I'm glad you like it oh Tessa I'm sorry
to put more pressure on you but I have
no it's my fault I have a two-part
question about adapting a book to film
because that can be a very challenging
process so having gone through it now
what one piece of advice would you give
to another author about to go through
that process for the first time but then
also what is maybe a misconception about
the experience of adapting your own
source material to film
I don't know if I know of a
misconception I'd have to hear what
other people think and then figure out
that they're wrong but what I would say
is
um collaboration is key it's vital as
the author of a novel
um just necessarily you need to see it
through very specific lens and when
you're adapting it into film that lens
is the camera and you have to think like
a cinematographer and a director and you
have to think like the character and you
have to think like the character 10
years ago and you have to think like a
writer
um so collaborating with people who can
help melt away the limits of your
singular perspective and offer other
ways of seeing your project is you know
crucial the way you describe it makes it
sound like such like a creatively
fulfilling and exciting experience it
has been so much so that I can't
describe it it's fair enough Odessa and
Luke I am curious about your experience
shifting into film because the one-two
punch of Causeway and now having a film
Premiere at Sundance I mean it's a
pretty big deal and a pretty strong
entrance into this sector of
entertainment
yeah we planned it that way
Luke do you want to comment what's the
question what what inspired the shift
into film especially with two
Productions like these
I don't know if I can answer that other
than
um for me opportunity came and it's so
exciting to collaborate with otessa
she's you know such a singular mind
she's so facile and for us to get to
channel our humanity and our experiences
into a common vision and to do the back
and forth of a like really juicy
collaboration is something I would never
walk away from
William I'm coming your way now I was
reading the production notes there's
something in there that caught my eye
that I really like you said we've taken
a risk with the storytelling and then
you went on to say we've worked hard to
create a participatory psychological
Thriller I got two questions about that
first with the risky element of it what
part of this would you say felt like the
biggest risk and the most challenging to
convey to people like producers
financiers
Etc in order for them to understand that
it was a risk well worth taking
well I mean the materials not everyone's
cup of tea I mean I think it's my cup of
tea I think it's exactly the sort of
stories that I'm drawn to read in books
and watch on screen
it's dark it's um at times strange
because Eileen has this Vivid inner life
and we wanted to represent that visually
um but again you know it's it's risky
territory because
um
because people there's a tendency to
want to play safe
oftentimes especially in a very uh
difficult market for cinema at the
moment
and so that is why it's important that
we can make this film independently
because it gave us the freedom to do
that
um I also think what I mentioned risk
what I enjoy seeing very much is actors
taking risks on screen and you have to
create an environment where that can
happen and the only way you can do that
is if you build trust and I I like to
think that
the environment we had was trustful and
it allowed them to take a risk and you
know ultimately when actors take a risk
on screen
they put themselves in your hands
because at the hands of the editor
because they're handing over something
and they will trust you to make it work
so I'm just grateful that these guys did
that I'm happy that we had that set up
for the film and um
and I I think audiences will enjoy that
seeing that tonight when they see the
film for the first time I'm not going to
forget about my second part but I want
to follow up and throw this to the cast
what is something about William as an
actor's director and a leader that made
you feel like you could take those big
swings and risks while making Eileen
because he knows how to have a good
laugh
so if you mess up or make a fool of
yourself you can just laugh it off with
Will and then move on to the next thing
I think sometimes when you meet someone
who's really nice
you kind of brace yourself and you wait
for well when's the other shoe going to
drop
who who are they really and I can say
with a certain degree of independent
low-budget Cinema Authority uh there is
the shoe never dropped will was the same
person throughout no matter how much
stress was coming at us no matter how
much pressure and very very real
pressure to move on through a shot he
somehow body blocked all of it and
created a completely safe environment
for us to have as much time as we needed
to be able to feel safe to take those
risks and
um and so the longer that went on the
more I trusted him
but I trusted him from what I saw in
Lady Macbeth I just there was something
you just used the word Humanity there's
such a deep sort of throb of humanity
that runs through it and in in in some
very complicated characters and to be
able to hold someone in particular a
young woman in her glory and her
complication and her ugliness it really
it it made me feel very switched on and
I was very excited to see see what
happened next with this one it's a
beautiful answer Shea you want to follow
that up
I'm that was I'm overwhelmed that was a
beautiful answer
I'm not going to forget about my second
part because I like I like how you
describe it as participatory and whether
it's a psychological thriller or any
genre of movie I feel like movies should
always have that feeling yes I mean and
it's surprising that it doesn't and I
mean if I could just make it if I could
simplify what I mean by that it's you
know I want an audience to lean in and I
think the way you do that is by
including them in the storytelling
getting them to ask questions you know
who's this what's happening what are
they feeling what's going on here that
sort of and I think that is
in the writing it's in the performance
it's in the cut because you know a lot
of the edit was about
pulling information out so that an
audience would have to work to discover
and that's what I mean by participatory
Cinema and that's they're they're the
films I love
definitely one of my favorite qualities
of film in general uh Shea I'm forcing
you to enter this one first but
everybody in the cast feel free to chime
in on this I could talk about the value
of a good scene partner all day long so
can each of you name a Time on set when
a scene partner did something that
helped you access something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to without them
uh I I I felt a a lot of that with
Thomason
um
I
I you you know it's you take these
characters on because they scare you a
lot of times and you you don't know if
you're going to be able to figure them
out or if you do actually
and that's what they were saying about
will
um is it what I would get lost uh he
would be able to bring you know some
clarity to the character
same with Thomas and I I she she
possesses in a this is a very difficult
thing to do in acting is is to be in the
moment at all times in a scene because
everyone thinks that when they call
Action you can you can action between
action and cut but she's always present
and in giving you no matter if I if I
drop the mic she doesn't look like it
didn't I didn't drop she picks it up you
know what I mean and so
I I felt many times I mean one time we
had a scene by uh
we had it seemed by the fire that was
just you know it's a tricky five page
you know two-hander and she was just so
present in that and that but many
examples of it doesn't surprise me to
hear any of that
how about for you too a time a scene
partner helped you reach something in
your own character well
um I'd like to talk about one of the
most difficult scene Partners I have
ever had which was on this film which
was the cat
now as anybody who's ever made a film or
an especially an independent film knows
that there are passages in the day in
which you have an exact amount of time
to get a shot you must get the shot and
you must move on or you like it just it
just turns into a nightmare for
everybody on every level we needed my
character to open a door while getting
attacked by a cat
and this cat
who's very sweet and who I'd spent a
great deal of time with bonding so
please don't come at me PETA and
everybody because I love animals and I
have treat and I treated this cat with
the utmost respect this cat decided she
didn't want to act in this exact moment
so and we really needed her and I turned
to her and I said on behalf of the film
I'm going to make you do what your
character would be doing in this moment
whether or not you like it so I'm going
to be gentle but I'm letting you know I
am going to give you your performance
and we did the scene and I made the cat
look like it was attacking me and the
cat got so angry with me and I think so
offended that I had told her how to act
that she went at me for every other shot
and I was very proud of her and I think
that she really let me she really let me
access the the kind of the tension
between the two of us and so I was very
grateful that even though we didn't
start out in the best way we ultimately
went on a journey together and wound up
giving each other a lot more than either
of us bargained for Ray it went both
ways you brought something out of the
cat that the cat couldn't access and she
brought something out in me too
all right Thomas and you're out
come on it's so unfair
um
I think I've I've got two examples of
like actors playing off each other or
like something being drawn out of me
that
otherwise wouldn't have been drawn out
if it weren't for any orche
um
being my same pattern I think one of
them is one of those scenes is seen in
the bar where it's um and I don't want
to give too much away but it's kind of a
pivotal scene in this film for our
relationship and um and I think it was
I think a lot of what I brought to
Eileen's and Rebecca's relationship was
true to the real life relationship
they've kind of mentioned a bit before
but
um I'm kind of I've always been a bit of
like a shy mover and dancer and and he
had to get on like onto the dance floor
and just like do these incredible moves
that were true of the 60s and have
looked like she was having a good time
which she was and she was kind of
drawing me in drawing this like shy kind
of like awkwardness out of me which only
came out because she was there you know
kind of taiwakitewaka pulling it out of
me so um I think that and also I think
reading the script I didn't
you know it's really easy to see the
hatred that is between Jim and Eileen
but it's not easy to see that the the
love that is also there between them
this kind of combative love that they
have
um and Shea helped me find that love
because you know relationships between
parents and children are always very
complicated
um so it was it's not it wasn't just one
thing it wasn't just head butting and
hating each other there was something
deeper to it in in in in Shay allowed
that to be a thing you know I I just one
thing because you just help me remember
something and I'd like to it's going to
be weird but I'd like to contradict an
answer I gave in another interview
where I said that um that I was asked
what Eileen means for Rebecca and I said
I wasn't sure Eileen
necessarily means that much Rebecca
because Rebecca is like a Serial
monologue and she's always thinking
about herself but I remembered in that
scene your vulnerability actually was
one of the first times Eileen becomes
real for Rebecca and one of the one of
those things and that is one of their
first real moments where Rebecca is
fully present and she's not just
performing in front of someone
cool memory yeah I feel like embarrassed
I feel like I'm going red to a few
it's because the set feels sacrosanct
right and like it feels so strange
inviting people into it and will you
understand that are you just going to
make fun of us
going back to what you said about it not
being everyone's cup of tea if something
is everyone's cup of tea I probably find
it real boring so I'm here for the
challenge I have to wind down with you
soon oh Tess I wanted to throw another
one your way
being the being the person who
originated the story and you were
talking about it earlier about how the
story goes through a transformation from
stage to Stage to Stage when filmmaking
ultimately in the finished product what
surprised you most about your own story
and how it turned out
you know I always wonder like do
stand-up comedians want to laugh at
their own jokes
this movie like I I what surprises me is
I feel like this is just this completely
different entity
um apart from the idea that I had in
2011 for the novel
um it's it totally has a life of its own
um and it feels really really alive and
managed to move me even when I knew
exactly what was going to happen at
every moment it I mean not in every
performance it it moved me deeply
I'm so excited I have no transition for
this we always like to ask about some
upcoming projects I'm just very excited
for Sesame Street and to see what that
turned out to be I have two questions
about that if we could if not it's it's
it hasn't happened yet I hope it does
if if that's the case if you could
answer this if you don't want to it's
totally fine but you've you've stayed
attached to that with many delays for a
long period of time you are very very
busy and oftentimes when that happens
someone drops out so what is it that
makes you want to stay to it stick with
it and hopefully see it through to
fruition if it happens one day oh fear
no
um
well I mean
I don't really make movies that I don't
love
and even even if it's a strange love
even if it's a love that doesn't make
sense to other people and even by the
way if the final product isn't in any
way what I thought it was going to be if
it doesn't spark something
um I I can't I just I don't think I can
do it and so when you read something and
you're genuinely Charmed or it's
something or delighted or it brings you
Joy or it's something that you want to
share with others it's really hard to
step away from things like that that
move you authentically and you know and
this is a funny business like things
movies take 20 years to get made and
um and there is something really really
satisfying about sticking with certain
things and there is something really
great about looking out and saying oh my
gosh I can't believe it for like eight
years I was the only person who
understood this and I really and all
those people who had my back believed
him and so it's just it's a wonderful
story it doesn't always work out
sometimes eight years later you're just
like I think it's time to call it it's a
mixed thing it's a and I'm really lucky
that so far I've been able to have a
career in this industry so I've had all
sorts of different experiences I feel
like I'm rambling and I'm just gonna put
the mic down knowing someone believes in
a project to that extent will always up
my interest more so than anything so the
fact that you feel that way about it
still leaves me hyped about it but I
also want to say that what we do is
highly experimental and you know what
you're saying about if some if
everyone's gonna love everything then
you can question whether or not enough
risks were taken or or whether or not
you played it safe to kind of appeal to
the most the widest possible audience
and if you are interested in filmmaking
as a sort of experimental version of art
there's a really good chance that it's
not going to work and it's a really big
ask of audiences to say I know I know
please please keep coming back because
when it hits we all know what what it
means but it does mean that sometimes
you have to eat some failure and that's
cool too
keep taking those chances even if it
involves some failure keeps me on my
toes keeps me excited and it keeps me
caring about what you all make
congratulations Eileen on Eileen again I
cannot wait to see this film thank you
for being here too and sharing some of
your experience with our audience to
everybody out there you keep an eye out
for Eileen as well and stay tuned we'll
have more from Sundance 2023 for you
very soon